autour de la possible candidature d'eric
zemmour n'en finit pas d'inquiéter la
classe politique pour la première fois
eric zemmour atteint 11% d'intentions de
vote si l'actuel éditorialistes ne s'est
pas encore positionné sur ses ambitions
futures ses apparitions à la télévision
se multiplient j'appelle ça
l'assimilation donc nous sommes assiégés
ma droite c'est le général de gaulle une
ambiguïté qui dérange et qui pousse
certains élus à le boycotter au fur à
mesure que s'expriment en portage de
moins en moins de choses avec lui était
le cas de tristan duval maire divers
droite de cabourg qui a décidé d'annuler
la venue d'eric zemmour au festival
littéraire alors qu'il devait y faire la
promotion de son livre elle devait s'y
rendre à 23 et 24 octobre finalement il
a été d invités par le maire de la vie
un choix qui divise alors le maire de
cabo at il eu raison d'annuler la venue
d'eric zemmour dans sa ville ce soir
tristan duval et jean messia se font
face sur notre plateau je remercie
tristan duval maire de cabourg d'être
venu nous voir a expressément sur le
plateau en direct merci beaucoup parce
qu'un jour on parle de vous tourner pas
de cette décision si si vraiment ça a
été énormément commenté cette décision
d'annuler la présence d'eric zemmour au
traditionnel salon du livre et y agents
messia merci à jean veste ya d'être avec
nous président de l'institut apollon est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec la
décision de tristan on va en parler dans
un instant juste je voudrais savoir et
interroger tristan duval le maire de
cabo sur
le fait prendre cette décision est ce
que ça a été parce qu'il ya eu
énormément de pression ou est ce que
c'est une volonté de votre part non il
n'y a pas eu de pressions des auteurs il
ya eu un maquis mazarine pingeot non
mais c'est pas vrai d'autant plus
qu'elle vient pas au salon du vide
accord donc c'est au sein fausses dents
c'est faux c'est d'accord je comprends
la nécessité pour certains de lancer un
buzz un nouveau buzz autour d'eric
zemmour et à de nouvelles polémiques et
d'instrumentaliser les choses la réalité
c'est qu'on avait invité eric zemmour
bien avant pendant l'été lorsqu'on avait
la liste de ceux des auteurs de la
rentrée littéraire et il y en avait de
nombreux et quand on s'est rendu compte
que ça glissait vers quelque chose de
très politique on s'est rendu compte que
ça dénature l événement que c'est un
événement au service des auteurs au
service de la littérature que sa
présence à l'est phagocyter tout le
reste est donc on a sauté d'autant qu'
il manque pas de tribunes c'est pas
comme si on parlait de quelqu'un qui
manquait de temps d'antenne médiatique
en plus le csa m décidé de ne de comptes
de comptabiliser de considérer comme
comme un candidat donc c'est une
décision donc c'est pas difficile
politique non c'est une décision
politique surtout qu'on leur a dit moi
je n'ai pas eu en direct eric zemmour
mais on leur a dit il est bien venu au
salon du livre sicile et il enlève cette
ambiguïté de savoir s'il sera candidat
oui s'il sera pas candidat s'il n'est
pas candidat il peut venir au sein de
l'ip et il peut venir aussi à cabourg en
tant que candidat faire un meeting faire
des signatures faire tout ce qu'il veut
mais à un moment on organise un salon
littéraire où l'idée c'est de mettre en
avant les auteurs certains d'entre nous
ont écrit des livres savez que c'est
très compliqué on met des années ont été
difficiles avaient prédite et et tout
d'un coup on se retrouve avec une rock
star qui va prendre toute la place et
donc c'est pas du tout ni de l'interdire
ni ni de la censure ni quoi que ce soit
c'est tout simplement on a voulu servir
notre événement littéraire cabourg c'est
leur vie la ville de marcel proust on a
créé un musée sur les
que vous avez lu en entier je sais
assure son frère alain
[Rires]
on a créé on a créé un salon on a créé
un musée sur la villa du temps retrouvé
où on peut prendre un thé boire des
madeleines avec des groseilles pour ça
qu'ils le souhaitent mais tout
simplement on a voulu être au service
des auteurs et alors si mais je n'ai pas
que ça allait faire une polémique parce
que nous on n'avait pas communiquer là
dessus ni en amont est sûr qu'ils
allaient sortir alors c'était sûr que
avec sortir pour l'instrumentaliser ne
s'était pas notre intérêt à nous alors
vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord a
encore exemple je pense que les gens
sont géants dans une des grottes et
parce que la vérité c'est qu'eric
zemmour en ce moment il écrase tout sur
son passage il fait une émission sur ces
news il est numéro 1 il fait un débat
sur bfm tv en prime il est numéro 1 là
il va potentiellement faire un salon du
livre c'est potentiellement la star du
salon au détriment des autres auteurs
donc on l'enlève du salon pour moi c'est
pas une raison valable et à ce moment là
pourquoi on accepter les anciens
présidents comme nicolas sarkozy par
exemple on n'a jamais accueilli nicolas
ce nom mais il avait 25 avril mais nous
on s'était mis comme règle de se dire
s'il y avait eu d'autres auteurs qui se
seraient présentés également on l'est on
leur aurait dit c'est pas la place c'est
pas un événement politique ce n'est pas
un événement c'est pas une tribune
politique ça fonctionne on a considéré
que l'adn vous avez vous avez des
rédacteurs en chef qui désigne qui
définissent l'ordre où l'esprit d'un
événement ça sortait du cadre de ce
qu'on voulait faire de cet événement
littéraire mais quand vous avez été très
bien sauf s'il avait ou non il n'est pas
candidat françois hollande non mais
quand l'autoroute a61 autres candidats
on au réarmement on en aurait assez
nancy elle m'a arnaud montebourg il est
en train de faire un album panini
juste jean message de cette très colère
là dessus un oui parce qu'en fait c'est
aucun des arguments nenê convaincante
pas me convoquer par mois mais voyant
mes bons coups mais pas non plus et
français parce qu'à la limite tous vos
arguments peuvent être utilisé contre
vous si effectivement la venue d'eric
zemmour et politique dans ce cadre votre
décision les politiques aussi voilà donc
justement mais alors vraiment ça fais de
la politique mais dans ce cas-là ça pour
ça ça pose un gros problème si vous
voulez ça moi je pense que c'est une
espèce de petite manoeuvre on va dire un
peu minable info le bien le dire deux
fois pour pas que pour pâques heureux
eric zemmour participer à votre salon
vous êtes macro nice tout le monde le
sait eric zemmour se bat contre le
progressisme et la marque ronnie donc
votre décision elle est purement et
simplement politique mais en tout cas
sur le sur le salon du livre c'est une
vraie connerie finalement parce
qu'effectivement comme disait guillaume
genton il ya un instant vous avez vous
avez empêché le salon du livre d'avoir
un vrai coup de projecteur on s'y
intéresse maintenant négativement pour
ceux qui sont annulés on eût aimé s'y
intéresser pour ceux qui sont présents
et sauret et donner un éclairage à votre
salon que malheureusement vous n'avez
plus mais je termine mon propos se
faisant finalement vous êtes un peu
l'incarnation de la macro ni c'est à
dire la grandiloquence et la flamboyance
et lorsque vous avez une petite minorité
d'auteurs comme il ya des petites
minorités des petits des petites
associations anti mère qui s'enflamme
vous vous car à pattes et vous vous
aplatissez devant les minorités c'est le
sens du gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
depuis maintenant cinq ans et dans le
beaujolais 18ème ou la poésie
dans le gouvernement démonstration des
niches lorraine alors justement tiens
tiens question de questions de tristan
est ce que vous avez des nouvelles
d'eric zemmour est ce qui vous a parlé
de ça quand vous êtes on sait cette
proche d'eric zemmour oui mais enfin et
lui si vous voulez jeu pour dire les
choses trivialement saluant bouge une
sans lui en bouger sa patrie sa
tirade perdition mais parce qu'en fait
comme encore une fois enfin dernier vous
dit quoi eric zemmour tout le monde en
parle il n'a pas besoin du salon de
cabourg et là il serait il à détrôner
parce que il a promis d'aller à la
rencontre des français et vous voyez
bien qu'à chaque fois qu'il voit dans un
noir français vu ça c'est un succès
phénoménal et absolue plus ou moins
arrosé de priver d'une ok
c'est ainsi je suis jeune eric zemmour
ça monte dans les sondages la droite
avait eu le dernier sondage oui crédité
de 13% mais qui en doutait quoi qu'ils
en doutent et attendez pas ce qui va
marcher devant peut-être dont marine le
pen oui donc vous êtes content d'avoir
quitté le rassemblement national ben moi
j'ai pas quitter je suis pas si bas je
suis pas prophète chez pas de vin quand
j'en suis parti je n'imaginais même pas
que zemmour a les mêmes faire oeuvre
d'un des buts comment ce brave rêve ou
et de candidature n'a bien sûr pas vrai
je sais que vous étiez proche d'eric
zemmour oui je suis un mercredi eric
zemmour est un ami depuis dix ans il
voulait dans le corps on a bien vu des
gens l'ambition parce que j'ai pas
encore ça mais est ce que dira j'ai pas
attendu les deux laiteries les dernières
semaines pour savoir et pour le et pour
le voir et pour pour lui parler je lui
parle en réalité depuis des années quand
je les ai vus au mois de novembre
dernier au moment où j'ai quitté le
rassemblement national dansant dans son
esprit rien n'était fait je dérange pas
quand mais vous savez qu'il avait une
idée derrière la tête on ne va se parler
moment alors tu peux parler on va
vraiment donner honnêtement à ce moment
là ce n'était pas tout à fait clair je
pense que c'est une maïeutique quelque
chose qui a pris naissance dans son
esprit magnette y voit qu'effectivement
il ya une demande du pays et puis bon il
voit que la france réagit comme disait
le général de gaulle est ce que vous
pensez ce qu'il faut c'est faire
exactement va brasser dans la france va
mal aux français comme comme beaucoup de
gens qu eric zemmour va assécher marine
le pen il le fait la plus en plus qu'on
voit encore qu'elle a encore perdu
énormément de points dans les sondages à
la 16% alors qu'eric zemmour est à 13 ce
que vous pensez que ça va continuer la
montée d'eric zemmour et la baisse de de
marine le pen ce qu'on voit que
président macron lui ne bouge pas il est
vraiment c'est le seul stable dans les
sondages oui m'enfin bon parce que pour
l'instant personne ne s'y intéresse
vraiment il est président non ménagers
la prime aux sortants dont bernard et
pas du tout phénomène ben oui mais
jamais emmerdé vous voulez sont
déroulées sans âge compte que quand
c'est pour vous non non j'ai dit oui à
l'école de nicolas bonneau
n'en est pas du tout donc le sondage
c'est même le c'est drôle c'est quand le
président est crédité de 23 entre 23 et
26 % c'est pas voilà c'est pas parce
qu'on s'y intéresse pas c'est qu'il ya
23 mg entre 23 et 26 % d'intentions de
vote pour le président mais les 13%
d'eric zemmour c'est quand même et non
comme donc comment le programme ce qui
est intéressant si vous voulez encore
une fois c'est la dynamique c'est la
progression à s'arrêter à cinq ou six il
a il a connu plusieurs paliers l'a connu
8 puis 11 et maintenant 13 mai donc
effectivement il faut juger les choses
en dynamique de moyenne dans les iodes
ce qu'ils font mais c'est la question
qu'on veut que tout le monde voie verte
ici on voit bien qui siphonnent le rnd
se donne pas le président wim et adresse
que je veux dire c'est qu'en fait dans
le dans le camp national c'est à dire
tous les électeurs du rassemblement
national de debout la france les
sympathisants d'eric zemmour au lac est
la seule question qui vaille c'est au
second tour est ce qu'on a envie de voir
un débat macro le pen ou est ce qu'on a
envie de voir un débat macron zemmour
vous avez envie de toi ben moi j'ai
envie de voir macro zemmour pasaia
compte alors le baril de brent s'est
finie
ballon à messi bat signé ben addi bâ
tienne nous et le ciel nous regardent ce
soir était vraiment je remets siens
damit ricard et manuscrits cartes totale
quoi non pas du tout moi vous savez je
n'ai jamais eu de voila j'ai quitté le
rassemblement national au moment où
parce qu'eric zemmour est un ami pas
marine le pen je n'ai pas les mêmes
liens d'amitié avec marine duncan et
d'amour de quoi tout à fait honnête oui
c'est donc grande est-ce que vous allez
rejoindre eric zemmour s'il fait
campagne
pour l'instant si voulez moi je suis
chez vous je suis sur les médias les
challenges plus tôt mais tu peux partir
alors bonjour qui parle moi qui pensais
soutenir énorme et bien sûr bien sûr
j'en aurais dit dit la vérité
franchement là sérieusement non pas là
on rigole pas vous vous allez vous allez
suivre et rayonnant j'en écoutais
génération z pour l'instant j'en sais
rien on j'y suis je me suis
malheureusement plus de la générale et
celle un peu plus âgées mais mais voilà
je sais je sais pas je sais pas ce que
je vais faire honnêtement sincèrement je
sais pas ce que le faire via le gel a
jugé utile d une lettre sur l'unique d'y
aller de son ministre de l'intérieur
j'ai eu un engagement politique de
quatre années où j'étais en la politique
opérationnelle je fais des fédérations
je suis à l'arrière rencontre des
mairies des militants des adhérents et
cetera j'ai envie de faire un de faire
maintenant un peu autre chose que je
suis en train de faire ce que j'aime
bien ce que je suis en train de faire
pour l'instant on avisera bariolés c'est
avant vie nous avons envie de soutenir
eric zemmour ça allait le soutenir
s'ils se présentent ben je soutiendrai
je ne sais pas c'est qui votre candidat
préféré l'armée j'ai par jean luc
mélenchon non c'est vrai mais je sais
pas philippe poutou je suis je suis
comme les journalistes du service public
non mais sans le trait radio et vous
vous avez changé ah bon franchement vous
avez plus de couilles un dommage ou lui
la télé vous a changé en tout cas du
point de vue anatomique à sont toujours
là je suis content de savoir avant tout
cas au moins de vue moral elles sont
plus là non mais c'est vrai à morales
qu'on voit pas dit la vérité n'est
conditions eric zemmour on se dit les
choses en plus à l'heure où je vous
parle je n'en suis pas encore convaincu
parce que j'ai entamé un virage dans ma
carrière et je me dois le dire à lui
voilà pourquoi le virage 3 to l'année
risquent gros négocier un virage négocié
à un verre acheté ni je n'avais
donc pour l'instant vous les voilà vous
soutenez personnes je soutiens personne
je vous dis je suis aussi neutre que les
gens avaient du service public d'accord
impartiale cause et non la sortie de x
ça
c'est pas demain du pôle a sorti une pro
des fois je n'aimerais pas
de deuxième tiers mais on rigole savent
rajon missia ça va et ça vous a fait de
la peine pour marine le pen ce sondage
là
[Rires]
vous a fait de la paix détendez vous
dites oh vous savez en politique c'est
laisser le peuple et les gens qui
décident donc les gens et fait tout le
monde peut se présenter tout le monde
peut aller au devant des français et
quand on va au devant des français soit
il ya quelque chose qui se passe je
pense que c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer avec eric zemmour soit il ya
quelque chose qui ne se passe pas ou qui
ne se passe plus à allah et il a répondu
à la question
mais ça c'est le père fouras je n'ai
comme on l'a vu on l'a vu avec avec le
maire de cabourg tristan duval qui merci
d'être là d'ailleurs christian qui a dit
que lui n'avait pas médiatiser la faire
don de cette éviction du salon du livre
est ce que eric zemmour l'a fait sortir
pour se victimiser on le voit qu'à
chaque fois qu'il se victimise eric
zemmour ça monte dans les sondages est
certes encore parler lui
et on l'a vu avec la couverture de paris
match il a fait énormément de bien on
l'a vu avec les journaux people qui sont
sortis ce week-end qui nous fait aussi
énormément de bien bfmtv face à jean luc
mélenchon et ben voilà donc résultat il
prend entre deux et trois points dans
les sondages ce qui est énorme en une
semaine est-ce qu'il a esquissé lui qui
l'a fait sortir
c'est votre âge non non je connais tu
mens je vois là je pense que c'est eric
zemmour il a une cour à fond uniforme
sur toute la france il va effectivement
la rencontre des français et non mais
mais j'ai la question est-ce que c'est
lui qui l'a fait sortir nos noms pour
reprendre pour juste pour rire non quoi
rendre pour répondre à la décision de
monsieur de monsieur le maire c'est
toujours le en même temps en fait vous
êtes dans la bienveillance et la
tolérance mais quand ça vous arrange pas
vous écartez je vous dis vous êtes un
grand démocrate et un grand pluraliste
mais quand l'idée est différente de ces
des idées que vous défendez on dégage
finalement on découvre avec vous enfin
pour ceux qui ne voyaient pas encore que
le progressisme l'autoproclamé
progressisme bienveillant tolérant
démocrate pluraliste est exactement l
inverse que le visage avec le siège
maintenant auprès des français eric
zemmour je vois plus faire le tour des
plateaux on peut venir auprès des
français bat cécile quand il
est le bienvenu pour faire une campagne
politique s'il le souhaite mais pour le
salon du livre ça ne correspond pas à la
dore à l'esprit deux années passées non
j'ai pas eu de pression j'ai pas eu de
pression des auteurs simplement c'est
vrai que nous on voulait un événement et
on l'avait invité à un moment où il ne
prenait pas tout cette place-là l'est
resté c'était en amont même s'il était
déjà chroniqueur télé évidemment enfin
polémiste mais simplement ça de sa
fenêtre déséquilibrer les auteurs au
contraire parfois il y en a qui disent
on a une locomotive salle mercinier les
autres excès alors nous s'est il allait
prendre toute la lumière si vous faire
une réunion publique et faire une
signature à cabourg il vient quand il
veut mais ça ne correspondait pas à ce
qu'on voulait faire de ce salon du livre
comme on en est quand même les
organisateurs et qu'on décide de
l'esprit qu'on veut en faire nous a paru
inopportun de l'inviter dolphin je pense
que les français aiment bien le l'effet
de croissance rapide comme macron a fait
il ya quelques années et là comme c'est
mourir je vous dit ça pour moi bien d'un
côté rien côté d'existence comparé à par
exemple la famille le pen ou d'abord il
y avait le père qui est l éternel second
troisième puis la fille puis la filleule
ça c'est plus plat donc je pense c'est
pour ça que vous et cartonné pour votre
salon du livre mais je ne serai pas
tout le monde en parle une municipalité
pouvait avoir un droit de regard en
fonction des flotteurs parce que il a
quand même écrit un livre d'autres c'est
un auteur qui étaient tous légitimes à
venir sur votre salon pour faire des
dédicaces pour rencontrer ses fans
puisque c'est ça le but savais pas
qu'une municipalité d'un droit de regard
vous aimez pas vous mais fait
charbonnières et vous ne vouliez pas que
votre salon soit politisée et politique
mais en le refusant c'est exactement ce
que vous faites donc je vous poserai la
question si emmanuel macron cette année
avait sorti un livre vous auriez
vraiment refuser ça aux questions on
aurait on l'aurait acceptée en marge de
type à la mode de caen peu d'un autre
évêque nous auriez refusé oui on en est
passé de cet orage que ceux normalement
on va dire les personnalités de ce
niveau qui sortent des livres ils font
ils organisent leur propre tournée
qu'ils organisent leur propre show il ya
des gens qui sont proches du public il
avait assuré par il donner à d'autres
auteurs y apparaît alors qu'amiens de
cabourg vous n'avez pas donné votre
signature à eric zemmour non non j'ai
pas vu la signature avec zemmour c'est
sûr ah oui c'est sûr la donne est acquis
et manuel macro mais c'est bien de dire
attention ces publics un nom mais pour
seulement ces publics j'avais annoncé
lors du premier mandat et du coup on
comprend donc c'est pas ça rien à voir
avec ce rêve où j'étais sûr qu'il allait
sa main oui enfin ça m'étonne pas
concerné et vous lui dites pas que il
manque de courage avec les thèmes que
vous aviez vous avez
je
m'appelle les tripes à la mode de caen
ça je vais te dire pourquoi pourquoi il
ya un très beau que tu te dis un très
beau petit hôtel à cabourg et j'ai pas
bien
être et détente oui ce qui est
intéressant de voir rapport au phénomène
zemmour c'est que j'ai appelé la mairie
de cabourg vos services vous croulez
sous les lettres et les appels de gens
qui veulent que zemmour viennent ces des
appels de gens de cabourg et de gens de
la france entière vous êtes submergés
d'appels pour vous dire changer votre
décision est ce que vous allez infléchir
la décision on est plutôt dans ces films
on est plutôt submergé d' insulte par un
certain nombre de fans ou de fait
uniquement de sécurité interne qui est
qu'il enrichit sa décision si c'est la
majorité palmer vous êtes une essai des
siens à l'horoscope aux minorités à 13%
vous avez une minorité sylla
donc mais 28% oui et 61% grâce voilà
donc ses jambes issia c'est tous vos
fans encore un nouveau tournoi
commence c'est vrai vous vous êtes vous
toujours votre compte twitter fermé
ouais j'ai porté plainte aujourd'hui de
william goldnadel mon avocat qui a une
assignation en référé d'accord vous avez
du temps vous